what if before the identity of my name
was the identity of pure consciousness
this pure Consciousness not having a
location
but rather spread out as a web across
all people
what if before all my labels of
nationality career
sexuality politics
was a Unity of pure love looking out all
eyes at the same time
what would change if I could feel the
Perfection inside of myself
that we normally seek in outside objects
and experiences
what would this peace and completeness
enable in My Relations
foreign
I would become transformative space for
whatever work wants to be done
I would let go of my Habit to project
and move outside of myself for happiness
the ideas and programs that I run would
slowly come to a halt
freeing up my space
I would untangle my tight grips of
associating with endless labels
I would become more free and malleable
holistic and loving
inclusive cherishing
I go back to the moment I was born
and I realized I had none of these
labels
not even my name
I was pure perception
pure Consciousness pure love
pure innocence
Unborn
then I went on this contraction and
expansion Journey on behalf of learning
for Infinity
in my expanded home of pure
consciousness
I am Fearless
I can process any sensation
emotion or alchemize the deepest pain
because I now know myself as the
indestructible space allowing anything
to happen
[Music]
I no longer see separation
as I am everywhere and nowhere
I see this space in all eyes
and feel Transcendent love everywhere I
look
[Music]
I have found the ultimate the Supreme as
the diamond of pure Consciousness inside
us all
fear not
as you have never left your throne
remember it
if you so wish